[Musique]
en
cours
la légende raconte que dans les îles
marshall la vie n'existerait pas sans la
présence du cocotier
le destin des hommes est ici intimement
liée à cet arbre
avec la pêche la récolte est depuis des
siècles la principale activité de cet
archipel qui compte près de 60000
habitants
les ressources sont rares et la noix de
coco est bien plus qu'un simple fruit
nourriture matériaux de construction
elle est présente partout
pendant quelque temps les îles marshall
ont même fait le rêve de l'utiliser
comme carburant ou plutôt comme
biocarburant
instituteur à la retraite
le vieux qu'ahidjo est marié à la fille
du chef coutumier
à tous les visiteurs de passage quelques
jours raconte la même histoire
le lien étroit qui unit la population à
l'arbre de vie
et le destin de ce fruit qui a failli
changer le cours de la vie dans ces îles
du pacifique
[Musique]
les cocotiers on s'en sert pour tous est
un combustible
il ne sert à construire nos maisons et
nous nourrit aussi et on en extrait le
coprah la mangue séchée de notre coq au
vin que prend la ville
ont fait tellement de choses et c'est
haro qu'il est notre arbre de vie
on s'en sert même comme carburant la
place de l'essence
c'est bien parce qu'on peut le produire
nous mêmes on n'a plus besoin de
personne passera
le rêve des îles marshall résumer en
quelques mots ne plus avoir besoin de
personne
le pays est éloigné de tout mais il n'a
pas complètement échappé au
développement
la capitale machureau offre le visage
d'un monde moderne avide d'énergie
lusine tobo l'art quitterait toute la
production de coprah du pays fabriqué
depuis sa création en 1979 de l'huile
alimentaire vendus aux etats unis
il y a dix ans jerry kramer le fondateur
de lusine à une intuition la noix de
coco n'a pas encore livré tous ses
secrets
il découvre ses vertus de carburant et
imagine donné à l'archipel son
indépendance énergétique
mon père est un pionnier il a fait des
choses en lesquelles personne ne croyait
il a eu une fois incroyable inscrits en
sa capacité à devenir indépendant grâce
à ces ressources
[Musique]
la pulpe de la noix de coco à rival
usine séchées en provenance de toutes
les plantations des îles marshall
elle est alors pressé et filtrée pour
donner une huile aux vertus diététiques
reconnu
aux etats unis huile de noix de coco et
même aujourd'hui recommandé dans la
cuisine pour lutter contre le
cholestérol et les maladies
cardiovasculaires
en s'inspirant des travaux de rudolf
diesel le créateur du moteur du même nom
kraemer à l'idée d'utiliser l'huile de
coco comme biocarburant pour les
voitures les bateaux ou encore les
groupes électrogènes des îles marshall
au dessus de 25 degrés l'huile garde des
qualités qui lui permettent d'alimenter
directement à moteur ça tombe bien ici
la température ne descend jamais en
dessous de ce niveau
lusine peut traiter 50 à 60 tonnes de
coprah en 24 heures
avec ses 60 tonnes on extrait environ 20
tonnes d'huile
wheaton baril le contremaître supervise
l'activité d'une trentaine de personnes
depuis la découverte de kramer l'usiné
fabrique toujours de l'huile alimentaire
pour les états unis méthot dollars
fournit aussi du biocarburant à toute la
population locale
une aubaine pour un pays éloigné des
grands marchés et chaque année un peu
plus touchés par la route sans fin des
prix du pétrole
les îles marshall se sont soudainement
mis à rêver d'indépendance énergétique
pour faire tourner les usines tobo l'art
tout l'archipel a intensifié sa
production
wilton et le capitaine va jo se rendent
souvent arnaud 25 km à l'est de
machureau et le bateau carbure bien sûr
à la noix de coco
100 % pur noix de coco ça sent bon non
[Musique]
une végétation luxuriante bord de la
côte des cocotiers à perte de vue
arnaud et lille qui fournit le plus de
coprah lusine tobo l'art
wheaton et le capitaine bajot se
partagent le travail
le capitaine fait le tour des petites
criques pour récupérer la marchandise
déjà prête pour l' usine de la pulpe de
noix de coco sécher
whitten lui seront de ferme en ferme
pour faire passer un message
lusine tôt bollard a besoin d'augmenter
sa production la demande est forte et
dans les plantations elle la récolte
doit suivre
[Musique]
il y encore trois ans je ne venais ici
qu'une seule fois par semaine maintenant
avec l'augmentation du prix du coprah
j'viens quatre fois par semaine les gens
produisent plus parce que le prix du
coprah à grimper
[Musique]
demande locale grandissante en
biocarburant demande en huile
alimentaire pour l'exportation le prix
du coprah a flambé et les effets s'en
ressentent dans toutes les îles marshall
pressé par l' usine mais aussi par des
acheteurs intermédiaires qui viennent de
plus en plus fréquemment chercher la
production la population locale
redoublent d'efforts pour suivre le
rythme tous les deux mois des cargos kit
machureau pour acheminer l'huile de coco
vers les états unis
tout le monde met la main à la pâte
[Musique]
moi j'ai arrêté l'école à 9 ans j'ai
commencé à travailler dans le coprah
partir de ce moment là
je le fais pour aider ma famille à
gagner de l'argent
grâce à l'activité générée par le copain
de nombreuses personnes partis tenter
leur chance dans la capitale ont choisi
de regagner leur île
[Musique]
dans le contexte local travailler à la
récolte de la noix de coco est encore le
moyen le plus sûr d'avoir un salaire à
la fin du mois un salaire dont la
progression est néanmoins bien loin de
suivre la hausse du cours de l'huile de
coco qui a doublé en un an
[Musique]
pour aider les habitants le gouvernement
envisage de doter les fermiers de presse
individuels leur permettant d'obtenir
leur propre carburant pour alimenter
groupes électrogènes et moteurs de
bateaux
[Musique]
j'écoute
pas d'alerté ou là
j'ai presque gêné
apte à récupérer des sacs
trois tonnes et aura fini quand dans
deux heures
à majourau l'utilisation de l'huile de
coco comme carburant de substitution est
présenté comme un exemple à suivre
mais à la fin de l'année dernière le
rêve s'est brisé
les îles marshall sont brutalement
confronté à la flambée des prix des
matières premières les marchés dictent
leur loi des cours fixé dans des bourses
situées à des milliers de kilomètres de
l'archipel vont interrompre la marche en
avant vers l'indépendance énergétique
tant espéré
nous avons dû stopper la vente locale de
l'huile de coco comme biocarburant
les cours mondiaux des huiles végétales
sont extrêmement haut
c'est devenu beaucoup plus intéressant
de vendre toute l'huile comme l'huile
alimentaire pour l'exportation
le prix du diesel a grimpé mais le prix
de l'huile alimentaire à grimper encore
plus vite
oui nous observons les prix du marché
des huiles végétales et les continue à
monter toujours plus haut
évidemment c'est le prix du diesel
repasse au-dessus nous recommencerons
avant de l'huile comme carburant
cela sera de nouveau intéressant
fable de la mondialisation
les îles marshall qui avait rêvé
autosuffisance énergétique et
développement durable sont rattrapés par
une réalité économique à laquelle elles
doivent se plier
l'expérience qui était suivi de près par
d'autres îles du pacifique tourner court
le coco vaut de l'or en huiles
alimentaires et il disparaît de tous les
moteurs des îles marshall
[Musique]
les compagnies pétrolières sont sans
doute là pour longtemps encore